one question that i have for you is so
you're when you're 22 so you're when you
were 32 you fought uh
john who was 24. am i saying i correctly
was 32 32 to 24
and his reach was 84 and a half i want
to say you were 75
you know uh weight obviously the same
height he had you on you know whatever
however many inches he has you honor
because he's a taller guy he's a 645 but
he came through you were like an older
brother so you haven't seen a different
side of him he's nice right now believe
me richard's got a different highlight
but but i want to talk to you but i want
to go back and ask a question here about
coming up so if you
were 22 today
and you know you can ball you know you
can hang in there you know like listen i
think i can take this guy down right i
can fight this guy but the comp
structure and the opportunities are
different today than they were when you
were 22 right you're seeing this whole
thing with jake paul and dana going back
and forth and hey pay him this i'm
paying that and you're seeing what jake
is making you're seeing what woodley
made with a fight you're seeing what
mayweather is doing what conor did so
the model is different you got boxing
ground you got the youtube rod you got
the ufc round what how different of a
game plan would you have today with your
wisdom today being 42 20 years older
than i mean 22.
what would you tell the 22 year old
rashad evans today which route to take
well i mean it's all about now um
getting the following you know we live
in such a culture right now where it's
all about the following and you know
getting the people's interests you know
whatever it may be that you do that
stands out among the crowd you know
accentuate that and really stand upon
that and really start to push yourself
in that direction and then from there
you know you can start to navigate which
fights that you want because you know
the promotion or whatever it may be
they're going to make sure that they put
you in a position where they can get the
return for your value because it's all
about the value you know people want to
pay you for what your value for if you
don't have the value you can be the best
fighter in the world but you're not
going to get that money
so so in other words
would you say
you'd be somebody that'd be documenting
your vlogs your fights your training to
get a youtube channel to get a few
million subscribers and then maybe
have some of the instagram how how would
you create that following would you take
the jake paul route would you take the
logan paul route would you take the
connor round what what route would you
take you know uh there's somebody
somebody doing really well right now uh
shigeshan o'malley he's he's uh sick
stole your nickname by the way yeah but
that's all right we're gonna run up on
that thing
it's all right though because the thing
about it is he's he's owning it you know
i'm saying he's making it his own and um
you know this kid if you watch him you
know uh can you pull him up so people
know who he is crazy hair white boy
skinny crazy hair white boy skinny uh
but he's a very interesting character
you know he um he's good to look at he's
fun to look at but he's got personality
and he just he just comes to life and
and and what he does is not only uh does
he talk a good game um he fights like
crazy he knocks people out even though i
feel like his level of competition
should be a bit higher but that's what
happens when you have that following
when you have that following they bring
you along the right way because they
don't want to ruin you in order before
they get the full value out of you and
that's one thing that he does really
well he's really good on social media
he's really good uh with his youtube
breaking down fights and all those
things
and he just has the interest that you
know he he speaks to the uh the
demographic of today and the huge
following so so you would you would
advise
you would like you yourself would still
go
the ufc route you would still go to ufc
route yourself if you were 22 today
except you would pay more attention to
the social media following or would you
say i'm going to go try to get part of a
you know de la hoya camp i'm going to go
part of canelo camp i'm going to go try
to be a boxer because that just pays
more you know canelo got a you know 12
fight 360 million auto contract whatever
the number was some insane number that
he got right i'm gonna go take that
route or no i'm gonna i'm gonna work my
way up on the ufc side and be the next
whoever what what rob would you take i
would say go to ufc route because of the
steal yeah well because of what boxing
is that you know um for so long before
you can even get to that level i mean
jake paul has been able to do something
extraordinary because of the fact that
he's built himself up way high before he
even put himself in a position to box so
that's like an anomaly out of the whole
situation but you know with the ufc you
know you can start off and really grow
in an organization and and if you're
like a guy like sean o'malley they'll
bring you along the way and you can
develop your skills at the same time you
know by and and develop who you are
outside of the cage as well too yeah i'm
just very very curious because you know
a lot of young guys see everybody and
they're kind of like what do i do now
yeah what role do i go now so you know
you seen a jake you know what was it did
you see the number that came out highest
paid athlete under 25. did you see that
45 million dollars he made last year so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]